Lichterglanz und festliche Stimmung:
Auf dem Berliner Breitscheidplatz ist
von dem Schrecken des Terroranschlags
vor fünf Jahren
im ersten Moment nichts mehr zu spüren.
Er wird diesen Tag niemals vergessen.
Schausteller Max Müller kam
knapp mit dem Leben davon,
als der LKW in den Weihnachtsmarkt raste
und seinen Stand komplett zerstörte.
Ich war an meiner Arbeit und
hab’ eigentlich nur ’n lautes Geräusch gehört.
Das hat sich angehört,
als ob ’n Müllcontainer abgerollt wird.
Wenn die Müllcontainer
hier getauscht werden,
dann gibt es immer so ’n „Rrrrrrrrr“.
Und dieses Geräusch war im Hintergrund.
Und ... ich hab’ mich umgedreht,
hab’ den LKW gesehen,
hab‘ gesehen, was passiert ist,
und bin dann ziemlich schnell
mit meiner Frau geflüchtet.
13 Menschen kamen bei dem
islamistischen Anschlag ums Leben,
mehr als 60 wurden verletzt –
bis heute ein schweres Trauma für
Deutschlands Hauptstadt und ihre Menschen.
Max Müller hat trotzdem weiter
einen Stand auf dem Markt.
Zeigen will er ihn lieber nicht,
weil er sich vor zu viel Öffentlichkeit
schützen möchte.
Arbeiten am Ort des Anschlags –
wie kriegt er das hin?
Ich würde behaupten,
dass ich durch gute Aufarbeitung
und auch gute Behandlung, die ich hatte,
gelernt hab’, definitiv damit umzugehen.
Und [es] ist natürlich etwas, was ja in der
Erinnerung is‘ mein ganzes Leben.
Und wenn meine Kinder mich mal fragen
werden: „Papa, wie war denn das?“,
dann werde ich sicherlich … kurz stottern,
bevor ich ihnen erzählen kann, wie’s war.
Auch viele Besucherinnen und Besucher
des Weihnachtsmarktes
ringen mit ihren Gefühlen.
Einerseits ist da die schöne Stimmung.
Andererseits sind da aber auch
Momente der Trauer,
vor allem am Gedenkort
für die Opfer des Anschlags.
Ich hab‘ Gänsehaut.
Da kann man nichts [da]zu sagen.
Wenn man die Lichter sieht
und die Würstchen riecht,
dann möchte man einfach ...
dann vergisst man mal kurz.
Es ist furchtbar, aber man kann‘s
auch nicht mehr ändern leider.
Kapitulieren vor dem Terror
war für ihn keine Option,
sagt Schausteller Max Müller.
Ähnlich denken auch seine Kollegen
hier auf dem Markt.
Wenn, dann ist es noch einfach drin
im Herzen, was man nicht vergisst.
Aber …
ich behaupte schon,
dass die Betreiber und dass das Umfeld
in gewissem Rahmen gesagt haben:
„Okay, wir müssen weitermachen,
wir müssen nach vorne blicken.“
Die Erinnerung an den Anschlag wird bleiben.
Doch im Zentrum steht
auf dem Breitscheidplatz
heute wieder das Weihnachtsgefühl.